Trump is appealing the main Secretary of
State's decision to boot the former
president from the 2024 ballot and while
dem's trying to stop Americans from
voting for Trump President Biden is
promising to have a
pulse what's your mayor resolution
sirse that's the biggest one right now
oh boy but his reelection prospects are
a different matter popular radio host
Charlamagne the God says he has no plans
to throw his support behind the big guys
re-election he just said quote in 2024
it's a race between the cowards the
crooks and the couch which is referring
to Biden Trump and the option to stay
home the god also feels particularly
burned by comma and added this quote I
learned my lesson from doing that once
they got in the white house she kind of
disappeared all right I'm going to go to
you Jessica seems is this the canary in
a coal mine moment is this a is this a
warning that he's trying to give to the
president that uh you can no longer take
the black vote for granted it is though
it's quite regular that he does this
which I I think is a service to
Democrats um to just say and this
especially pertains to uh the black male
vote not so much black women um but
black men have been expressing this
certainly through the Trump era and when
Biden was running in 2020 that it just
wasn't that exciting to them and they of
Unleashed campaigns they did the whole
Barber Shop tour which ended up being
successful and and President Biden was
obviously elected um but it is a concern
and there was a poll out today that
showed a staggering loss amongst black
voters down into the low 60s now I don't
think that anyone who's being an honest
broker about that thinks that Biden is
going to end up losing 20% of the black
vote off of what he got but it's
certainly a
concern the disappoint with comma is
something that I understand um but I do
wonder if there are any vice presidents
out there where people were like
particularly jazzed about or thought
like I I love this guy I mean Joe Biden
when you think back to his eight years
as vice president the real kind of
shining star example of what he got done
was getting gay marriage P that was his
portfolio that he was going to be part
of the lobbying effort it was a huge
moment for the country um and for the
party but KLA Harris is been put in
charge yes I know the Border but also in
terms of the messaging about the do's
decision and getting out the youth vote
and that's been hugely successful we've
won all of these ballot referendums
there was huge turnout in the 2022
midterms and the expectation is that
that will keep up so I don't know if
knocking her in that way is decision was
a gift kamla you didn't need kamla to do
that let's be honest come on Jessica
stop
lying
that 2024 humor yes yeah Jesse uh this
was interesting he also said uh he's not
looking for his politics to be pure
right and I think what he's getting at
is that the Purity goals of of the
Democrats keeps the goalpost moving so
you never know what's right or what's
wrong anymore what say you man with the
golden
hair the thank
you we don't on the Republican side
always need Purity either sometimes the
most staunch conservative politicians
don't end up winning that's why Trump
was so successful because he was a
little flexible in terms of his approach
to different issues but think about how
hard it is to disappear as Joe Biden's
vice president yeah Joe Biden has
disappeared that means you are seen and
heard from less than the president that
we never see or hear from
he's away from the White House in
Delaware 30% of the time all she needs
to do is maybe once every other week
make noise mhm and every time she does
make noise no one understands the word
she says a point
she was supposed to be cool remember she
wore her little sneakers all stars with
the pants suit she liked
Tupac she turned out to be some insecure
goofball who just runs away from crisis
after crisis
but the fact that he's losing his base
blacks Hispanics young Butters it's time
to Pander Greg yeah that means Biden's
going to come out with the
despacito Jill is going to call them
enchiladas again they'll probably make
HLA grab Hillary's hot sauce put that in
her purse it's going to be fun to watch
that legitimate she does carry she does
not carry Hot Sauce fact check by the
way I was right about Tiffany and Beres
she did appear on 902 she did but he did
think she was and dority true also true
judge judge the weird thing about
charlin's beef is that it's not about
crime or the economy or inflation or
gender policiy or division it's not
enough comma but does does he need comma
all of these issues are very leftwing
that's really a great point you have to
say you know what you should be more
worried about Joe because Joe's the one
who said to you if you have to think
about me or Trump then you ain't black
I'd still be carrying that ship from
four years ago but he says that that
people rely on his take because he says
he's neither Democrat nor Republican are
coming back and saying you know what we
relied on you we we we expected more
because you said this and here's the
bottom line he now is in in in position
where he doesn't speak for anybody all
right because no one is buying what he
said and so he's lost credibility and
that's what that's about and look 71% of
the country thinks that uh the country's
in going in the wrong direction and 71%
of people in Swing Swing States think
he's too old and here's where the
problem is with the black voters if he
loses by uh 0. n of 1% in Georgia which
is a swing state of black voters he
loses Georgia which he needs so those
numbers right now 20 points blacks 87 to
63 he dropped 24 points you may not
believe that that's how it's going to
end up but it just takes a sliver for
him to lose his swing state and the
amazing part of this is that Biden had
the benefit of abortion he has the
benefit of climate change and yet young
people in this country are not into him
they'd rather vote for Trump trump is AD
of Biden when it comes to young people
it's clear the young people 37% Trump 33
Biden so I mean for all the gifts he's
had he still is a mess he's just too old
even his wife had to remind him you'll
let to tell him your favorite food is
ice cream really you know Dana I once
the media maybe accepts the fact that
Biden's still going to run are they
going to have to reverse gears and now
push all this good news like before but
but before they were okay with the bad
news they figured maybe that would get
Joe out but now Joe might stick so now
they're going to say crimes down uh
illegal immigration is down everybody's
going to sound like a republican yeah
absolutely it could be I mean I was just
waiting for claudian gay to come out
with a statement that says Charlamagne
the God is a sexist and a racist because
imagine if in a color blind test
somebody said this and it turned out it
was you know you're Jesse what do you
think would would be the reaction so but
the those calls are coming from within
the Democratic party I know that we look
at a lot of polls but I like anecdotes
as well a young producer from America's
Newsroom is home for the holidays she
has friends that vote Democrat and they
said that they are not going to vote for
Biden Harris because they want to punish
the DNC so what you might have happened
is a coalescing from the media and
social media and maybe somebody like a
Taylor Swift that says look they might
not be perfect but it's better than the
alternative and that would be the hope
that they go into uh to the judge's
point about the margins for Georgia Carl
Ro today on America's Newsroom and you
can find this on the Twitter page we
call it or x x page for a newsroom he
went through the margins are so small
for President Biden that he could lose
all the swing states with just a little
sliver of these other voters blacks
Hispanics and youth in Arizona Michigan
Wisconsin Pennsylvania and of course
Georgia There You Go shouldn't somebody
point out to Charlamagne the typo andth
cuz I mean it's kind of embarrassing
you're an adult it's an article yeah
just three letters hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else